this is a hollowed out husk of what the
country was built on the basic principle
that we the people select our leadership
not the unelected elite class in the
back of Palace Halls the Colorado
Supreme Court removed former president
Donald Trump from the state's 2024
presidential ballot on Tuesday after
ruling that he engaged in an
Insurrection with his actions on January
6 2021 here's VC they have just tried to
Bar president Trump from the Colorado
ballot using an unconstitutional
maneuver that is a bastardization of the
14th Amendment to our US Constitution
this was a provision section three that
was designed to Bar Confederate members
people switch to the Confederacy from
actually being able to serve that's very
different than what's at issue here to
say the least this is a hollowed out
husk of what the country was built on
the basic principle that we the people
select our leadership not the unelected
elite class in the back of Palace Halls
that's Old World Europe not the United
States that's why I'm making a pledge
today that I will withdraw I pledge to
withdraw from the Colorado GOP Primary
ballot unless and until TR Trump's name
is
restored and I demand that Ronda sanis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same thing or else these Republicans
are simply complicit in this
unconstitutional attack on the way we
conduct our constitutional republic I
refuse to be complicit in that I think
what they're doing is wrong and I think
it's up to Republicans to step up and
stand up with a spine for our country's
future that's really what's at stake
whether we the people actually have a
say in deciding who leads this country
yes it would be easier for other
Republicans like me who are running in
this race to say hey if Trump is
sideline there's our opportunity no
doubt other candidates are probably
privately celebrating with their
corporate sponsors that's not the right
thing to do I think the most useful
thing that every GOP candidate can do
right now is to to join me in that
pledge I'll say that I will withdraw
from that Colorado GOP Primary ballot
until Trump's name is restored this
belongs to the people not to the
unelected Democratic cabal of judges in
Colorado or any other state and I demand
that Ronda sis and Nikki haey and Chris
Christie do the same thing or else
they're complicit in what this Security
State is trying to do to shut down Trump
I stand by that I expect him to do the
right thing he's making he's making his
political move that's what VC is very
good about like how do control media how
do you get the social media people
behind you who knows if VC was even
going to make it to the Colorado primary
also demanding anything from Dan santis
or anyone else whatever that's a little
silly but okay the heart of it I I'll go
with uh this is from the Colorado
Republican uh party you won't have to uh
this is in response to bbec you won't
have to because we will withdraw from
the primary as a party and convert to a
pure caucus system if this is owed to
stand